some of the most important discoveries
in eldon ring's early game are
surprisingly easy to miss for example
one of the most valuable consumables in
eldon ring is the flask of wondrous
physic which has its single charge
replenished every time you rest at a
grace checkpoint that alone should earn
it an esteemed place on your quick
select bar as it's the sort of thing you
should try to consume for every major
encounter
you can find your flask at the third
church of america located here but what
does it do well that's up to you by
mixing in different crystal tear
combinations at a grace checkpoint you
can alter its effects for example here
my crimson burst tear heals me over time
and my opaline bubble tear gives me a
shield that protects me from the next
attack i'll be hit by you can get both
of these tears from the field boss
fought here another essential item is
the whetstone knife which allows you to
apply ashes of war to your armaments you
can find the whetstone knife here in a
cellar underneath the gateside ruins
it's kind of crazy they hid such an
important item here but with this you
can now apply ashes of war to your
weapons and that allows you to give them
new skills and new scaling options to
better suit your build if you want to
quickly get a lot of ashes of war make
sure to visit banal during the day here
at the warmasters shack he sells an ash
of war that is perfect for you
no skill
i'm being serious though because it's
actually pretty good what you do with
this one is you apply it to a shield
that has something like parry or another
skill that you don't like and by
applying this to your shield it allows
your ash of war to default to your
weapons weapon art rather than your
shields
and if you find yourself wielding two
weapons then you might want to duplicate
an ash of war for both of them to do
this you'll have to trade an item called
lost ashes of war at the blacksmith and
you're going to want to talk to the
blacksmith pretty early since the
smithing table at the church of ella can
only get your weapons to plus three but
the blacksmith can take them well beyond
that to talk to him though will have to
be invited to the round table hold it's
hard to know exactly what triggers
melina to invite you here i know you
definitely get taken there if you defeat
margaret at stormville castle but
failing that you will simply get invited
just after exploring the world for a
little while and you can warp here at
any time in the bottom left of your map
defeating margaret is actually also
important because he gives you your
first talisman pouch with each pouch you
collect you gain another talisman slot
talismans are like rings from previous
games you only start with one slot but
in the end you can have multiple and
they offer diverse and powerful benefits
to your character
just like talismans your spell
memorization slots are now also tied to
items so if you want to memorize more
than two spells at a time then you'll
need to seek out memory stones your
first memory stone can be found at
iridis rise where you'll have to solve a
simple puzzle in order to gain access
and open the chest within
put this in your new memory slot the
world is a lot more dangerous at night
in addition to night enemies tons of
night bosses also seem to spawn so if
you're looking for more bosses to fight
and you think you might have missed some
in the early game
head here
here
here
and here you'll find some good bosses
here now to offset this apparent rise in
world difficulty at night in my
experience your roon acquisition at
night is also boosted and this is thanks
to three new mechanics the first
mechanic is this when the urge tree
graces you with this golden reign of
leaves you've just chanced upon a really
rare weather effect that buffs your
character what does this buff do
i'm not sure exactly the icon here is
that of a four-fingered foul foot which
has items that increase item discovery
and rune acquisition so it's likely that
this rain does something similar now the
official guide says that this rain
increases roon acquisition by four to
five percent so i guess that's likely to
be correct although my testing actually
revealed nothing of the sort the only
other option i can think of is that it
boosts item acquisition
whatever the case though it's probably a
good idea to farm some enemies while
this buff is active just based on the
icon if nothing else
the second thing to look out for are
enemies with golden eyes in my
experience these enemies drop four times
the amount of runes when you kill them
so if you see an enemy with golden eyes
go out of your way
i love this mechanic it really
encourages you to take up some fights
that you might just usually have run
past you know
last but not least be on the lookout for
glowing white skulls upon the ground
once broken apart these will give you a
golden rune consumable they spawn in
random locations and can easily be
looted by trampling them with torrent
and spamming the loot button some folks
will want to spend these runes on
becoming more powerful
but that's lame honestly
instead you should spend them on looking
good and
getting that elden bling what i'm doing
here is called armor alteration where
elements of some sets of armour can be
changed for a small price for example a
cloak can be added to the commoner set
and profits can be freed from the neck
piece of course every armor piece is
different so check it out for 500 runes
and see what changes to unlock armor
alteration you have to defeat the boss
of the demi human cave in south western
limb grave when you're victorious you'll
receive the tailoring kit and a sewing
needle the tailoring kit unlocks armor
alteration but the sewing needle is
actually a part of box questline box
quest line can be started in a grove of
trees located here and i suspect his
quest line might lead towards more armor
alteration now when i started this build
i wanted to be a glorious faithful kind
of valkyrie character then i found a
black crossbow a spell that cast
darkness and an evil looking flail these
things were way too edgy five me but
luckily an elden ring you can change
your character's appearance to better
suit your build so that's what i did
it's easy to miss but in fear's room at
round table hold go up to this mirror
this is the clouded mirror stand here
you'll be able to return to the
character creation screen and change
everything except your starting stats
and keepsake of course
make sure you frequently do return to
the round table hold to see if
anything's changed or if any new npcs
have dropped by roderica should be one
of the first new appearances here
you can talk to rodericka out in the
world here by the stormhill shack but it
doesn't seem absolutely necessary for
her questline for you to talk to her
here just progress through the game and
she should eventually show up at
roundtable hold whether you've talked to
her before or not after you've talked to
her in roundtable hold go and talk to
the blacksmith and then go back and talk
to her again and you can trigger a
progression in her questline after
reloading the area she will have found
her purpose as a spirit tuner someone
who you should return to frequently to
upgrade the strength of your favorite
phantoms of course if you haven't
already you can get the spirit summoning
bell from renner when you return to the
church of ella the resource used for
upgrading your spirits is called glove
wart regular spirits require grave glove
wart and special spirits require ghost
glove wart glavor is found all
throughout the catacomb dungeons
specifically and unlike other resources
it doesn't appear to respawn after
resting at a grace checkpoint so be sure
to loot these dungeons thoroughly number
nine is one of my favorite new things
they've added to the game bar none
paintings after you interact with one
the puzzle has begun your job now is to
go and find that place depicted in the
painting out in the actual world
this painting for example asked me to
find these gravestones i remembered
seeing them a while ago so i tracked
them down near the seaside grace and was
rewarded by the painter i got a scarab
head piece that increases my damage
taken but increases the damage my faith
spells do
this second painting was way trickier
and it was this one in stormville castle
i'm not going to tell you where it
depicts but i will give you an important
clue for all of your paintings going
forward remember you don't have to find
the place depicted in the painting you
have to find the location it was painted
from if you ever need to review the
paintings you're tracking then you can
find them in your inventory menu here at
the top of the screen a new feature in
eldon ring are group passwords unlike
multiplayer passwords which restrict you
to only interacting with people using
the same password group passwords simply
let you visually distinguish who is
using the same password as you and who
isn't you can still interact with
everybody for example this sign on the
left is using the same group password
and the sign on the right isn't the same
goes for phantoms and messages and even
blood stains and i think it would be
really cool to see others from our
community while you're playing the game
so i want to make a community group
called secret seekers a community
password will be seekers all capitalized
like that as a secret seeker it's your
job to drop your gold summon sign or a
message and guide others to a secret
whether that's a dungeon or a hidden
path nearby if you're happy with a
message then upvote it and if you have a
good co-op session that leads to finding
a new secret then consider dropping a
reward for your fellow seeker remember
our community password is seekers
oh and speaking of special codes if you
go to
audible.com or text vati video to 500
500 then you can claim your free 30-day
audible trial and get full access to
thousands and thousands of all you can
listen audiobooks original entertainment
and podcasts included in the plus
catalog additionally you'll get credit
for one full audio book completely free
and this month i'm recommending that you
download the audiobook for the lord of
the rings one ring to rule them all
one ring
to find them
one ring to bring them all
and in the darkness
bind them there's a couple of great
narrators for this one and you know it
just seems so fitting to recommend this
story now on the eve of eldon rings
release these are two stories about
rings of power that are set in enormous
worlds that really draw you into their
fantasy so maybe have a listen while you
do some grindy stuff in game like
foraging for materials or farming runes
or grinding enemy drops that's how i
tend to use audible i think it's pretty
fantastic to be inspired and productive
at the same time you know
so remember go to
audible.com or text devonte video to
500-500 and get your free trial started
so thank you to audible for sponsoring
this video
and thank you for watching
[Music]